the one thing I will say for a group
identity is that what we've seen is that
if there is lack of group identity that
group identity is filled usually by
nefarious groups meaning that that
people do have a necessity
the idea of existing that you find your
meaning or you find your purpose or you
find your identity just in yourself as
an individual is not only wrong it's
belied by virtually all of human history
Caroline it's an argument for identity
politics but but what Judaism does what
America does it says find your identity
in the ideas yeah right that's the
difference is when I mean this is why I
say I don't care about biological
Judaism particularly that I care much
more about the ideas that you hold so
I'm in favor of group identity if group
identity is built around a set of ideas
that are worth preserving I'm not in
favor of group identity it like I am a
conservative that's a group identity
right that's an identifier more than
it's an identity meaning it's a way of
identifying me as a person who thinks
this way and because I think there are
differences in modes of thought then
those group identities do matter I mean
this is why we get together this is why
we have discussions this is why we have
a family yeah yeah but I'm glad you I'm
glad you said that the way you did
because I try to challenge myself on
that all the time because I talk about
the individual I believe in the
individual and I want to make sure that
I'm not a commonality if I if we can fit
and this is what I think is one of the
things that's broken down is we used to
have a common purpose like I have this
framework that I'm working on in the
book that I'm writing where I basically
say that in order for an individual to
be happy you need you need four things
you need an individual purpose you need
an individual capacity that can fill in
that you can accomplish that purpose or
at least make moves in that direction
you need a communal purpose you do need
to feel like you are part of a group
that's moving in the right direction and
you need a communal capacity which both
allows the community to activate
together and also protects your rights
as an individual to do what you want to
do in pursuit of your individual purpose
and that's the apotheosis of happiness
and that's what I think the founding
fathers were trying to do in the United
States for example is set up a framework
where you could fulfill all of these
things but you do need the idea of
communal purpose and one of the things
that's happened post enlightenment is
that people don't even think in terms
they either think purely in terms of
communal purpose or not at all in terms
of communal purpose they think either
purely in terms of communal purpose and
that's identity politics meaning I'm
black therefore the black community
should do X right right or I'm Jewish
therefore the Jewish
community should do X and then there are
people who think not in terms of
communal purpose at all meaning full-on
libertarian I make my own meaning we
don't have to have anything in common we
in in that's a lie even libertarians
believe we have to have an idea of
Liberty in common mm-hmm I live with
other people right exactly harmoniously
and when we don't and when we don't have
any of the when we don't have any sort
of communal purpose and we live with a
bunch of people with whom we share
nothing then it falls apart incredibly
quickly